one day is defined as the vitality and
appreciation felt when one experiences
something new and transcending something
rich with revelation progress and beauty
something that seems to cause time to
cease and life to absorb into your being
where everything becomes clear and
peaceful life is synonymous with
progression it is constantly
accelerating towards something we do not
know what or even why but we do know
that we are a part of it and all we want
is to feel connected to it just as we
hate to be left out of social activities
with friends and family we would hate
even more to be left out of the activity
of life itself as members of nature's
evolution the most enthralling and
worthy pursuit is to experience that
which synchronizes us with its movement
to experience something unfamiliar and
advancing to touch the substance of life
and realize how connected we are to it
whether it is by continuously
progressing in something little by
little or by stepping into an entirely
new realm of possibility
it is the Associated wonder we feel that
connects us to life anytime we achieve a
new career goal or learn a new skill or
discover a new concept of life or even
just by new exposure to the senses like
the first time we hear a song that
brings us to a harmonizing state of
emotion that we have never felt before
or the first time we see an animal in
person whose massive size is so
unfathomable that we feel as though we
have been transported to a different
planet
or the first time we smell the lushness
of a tropical forest and it absorbs us
into a state of bliss these feelings of
wonder however big or small they maybe
are the essence of human life more than
any pursuit of happiness or wealth or
fame it is the pursuit of wonder that
truly brings us to life thank you for
watching if we found enjoyment and value
in this video please give it a thumbs up
share your thoughts in the comments
below and if you are not already be sure
to subscribe to our channel we are
constantly coming out with new videos to
help you experience life with clarity
and Wonder